en été bled en slovénie est une
magnifique peinture à noël c'est un très
beau dessin en noir et blanc avec 1 6l
en émail bleu mais la difficulté n'est
pas dans le dessin elle est dans la
légende
qu'est ce que noël dans une république
socialiste une tradition
1h d'autrefois qui sonne aujourd'hui
comme une pendule ancienne que l'on
croyait arrêté et qui tintent
inopinément sur la cheminée bien s comme
ailleurs une petite réserve d'espérance
il fois par an mise de côté pour les
mauvais jours
difficile à dire
ouais
en tout cas les vitrines mettent leurs
parures de soirée faite de verroterie et
de pierres précieuses - précieuse que
les pierres du décor naturel
et
on
oh
on trouve aussi des sabots devant
l'église et demain alter noël yougoslave
aura passé avec la barbe de karl marx
on trouvera
dans les sabots tous que latendresse
familiale aura pu loger d'indispensables
superflu
et l'on réveille onra exercice
couramment dénué de passion religieux
que les uns pratique tôt casino carpe en
surprenant que cela paraisse il y à un
casino à bled interdit il est vrai à la
population locale et jeux de hasard
n'ayant pas été socialisés et les autres
à l'hôtel
ou la cuisine yougoslave
multiplient le boire et le manger en
faisant étalage de ses mille et une
façons d'accommoder le veau le port et
le mouton point de boeuf peut-être
l'epargne ton en souvenir des services
rendus à la crèche le trion vraie
cuisine slovène
c'est la brochette qui rappelle le bon
vieux temps de la vente urnes au mad où
le cavalier faisait cuire sa nourriture
à la pointe de son espace d'eau
nato le brûlant tient ici le rôle du
bouclier chauffé à blanc sur feu de
décombres première version du barbecue
à
m
cette famille hollandaise en voyage
d'agrément il rend ce soir de découverte
en découverte
le monsieur hollande est chevalier at
bière dans son pays aura commencé par
goûter le vin et il va le trouver rouge
sauf connaissances spéciales il aurait
de la peine à en dire plus c'est en
effet un excellent vin de jérusalem et
jérusalem est un village viticole
fondée en slovénie par des croisés en
panne d'élan mystique
les dames elles ont charge
d'expertisé les plats
et on voit bien à ce quelque chose
d'absents et de concentrer qui voient
leur aimable regard qu'elles ne savent
pas ce qu'elles mangent elles ne le
saurons jamais ce sera un excellent
souvenir
la cuisine yougoslave est extrêmement
variée et elle supporte sur plus d'un
point la comparaison avec notre
insurpassable cuisine provençale
quand tu es son abondance je vous en
dirai simplement ceci qu'un bon repas
slovène se termine nécessairement par
une séance de tassement rythmique au son
des cuivres et d accorder leur de la
danse étant venu j'ai deux dernières
remarques à faire les costumes
folkloriques permettait tour d'un mur
demoiselle d'être toujours belle sans
jamais changer de robe avantage
appréciable
quant aux danseuses elle-même se
développe en ce moment sur le thème il
usa bhl du ballet conjugales il est à
noter qu elles ont tendance à se
ressembler d'un bout du monde à l'autre
bout point sur la hanche volts et
talonnades comme si la danse danse quel
ado net et de populaire n'était pas
autre chose pour les humains qu une
manière de se dire larmes au pied qu'ils
sont après tout les frais
mais oui des freins
non
vivant
on
mia
oh
sa validité
oui
j